Zwei Mikrofone, zwei Gesichter, zwei Herzen, ein Ziel. Gute Unterhaltung, was für eine Veranstaltung, achten auf korrekte Beitung, mit Stefan und Florentin. Zwei Gesichter, zwei Mikrofone, mehr kann man über diesen Podcast auch nicht sagen. Perfekt zusammengefasst. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Wir sollten unsere Texte ändern, finde ich. Manchmal steht da noch so ein alter Text als Beschreibung von uns. Weil jetzt sollten wir einfach zwei Gesichter, zwei Mikrofone. Weil ich finde, das ist so schön, ein bisschen blöd. Ja, es ist blöd. Es ist auch zusammengefasst, was wir eigentlich im Kern sind. Lass uns auch einfach den Podcast nochmal komplett umbenennen. Einfach das Podcast-Ufer hat sich, glaube ich, erledigt. Wir haben die Galaxie erforscht. Aber auch schon seit dreiemann Folgen. Wir haben, glaube ich, jeden Planeten besucht. Wir waren überall, es gibt nichts Interessantes mehr. Jetzt gibt es nur noch zwei Mikrofone, zwei Gesichter. Es sind aber so, als hätten wir zwei Gesichter. Also es gäbe Folgen, in denen wir gut drauf sind und Folgen, wo wir so Arschlöcher sind. Also jeder Podcast hat zwei Gesichter. Das wäre für mich der spannende Podcast. Zwei Mikrofone, vier Gesichter. Man weiss immer nicht. Das sind zwei Leute mit zwei Gesichtern. Genau, man weiss nicht, welches Gesicht redet gerade mit wem und so. Das ist dann auch ganz spannend. Ich habe immer, wenn jemand gesagt hat, wir müssen unter vier Augen sprechen, musste ich immer nicht genau, was man, na ja, also es gibt ja noch, es gibt das innere Auge, es gibt das dritte Auge. Was genau ist das innere Auge nochmal? Ist es so, das Auge ist mit, das Auge im Magen oder sowas? Ich glaube auch, aber so, gibt es nicht das innere Auge? Oder ist es das dritte Auge, wo man sich nicht hinfassen soll, weil da das dritte Auge ist? Dann müsstest du eigentlich mit deiner Augenphobie zusammenzucken beim dritten Auge. Fass dir da nicht so hin. Ah, hör auf, hör auf. Aber, und da habe ich mal gedacht, und Zyklopen, wie sagen die das? Ah ja gut, das ist natürlich... Lass mal unter zwei Augen sprechen. Ja, das wäre wahrscheinlich der erste Gag in deiner Zyklopen-Sitcom. Natürlich, ja. Genau wie, wirft da mal ein, hab da mal ein Auge drauf. Hab da mal ein Auge drauf. Ja, ZDF Neo, es klingelt. Wirklich. Was klingelt? Das Telefon klingelt. Von ZDF Neo? Es klingelt und klingelt und klingelt. Ich hänge da seit drei Tagen. Hallo. Oh ja, hey, schön, dass Sie endlich rangegangen sind. Ich hänge jetzt hier vier Tage lang dran. Ja, ich habe zu tun. Und zwar, ich würde gerne eine neue. Achtung, eine Mail kommt rein. Ich muss Sie kurz, bleiben Sie kurz dran. Und dann ganz langsam wird der Hörer weggelegt, klack, dann wird erstmal gesucht, so Brille rüber, über die Brille geschielt, wo der Knopf ist zum Halten. Ist das ein älterer Mensch oder ist das ein Spont? Das ist ganz egal für diesen Sketch, ganz egal. Klingt so weg, auf Hold, hat vielleicht auch aufgelegt, weiß er nicht mehr. Brille, Haarfarbe.
Dann wird, wie du beschrieben hast, bei deinem Ex-Professor, die Mauszage geht ganz langsam rechts rüber. Mit dem Mini-Winni-Würstchen an der Seite. Das Mausrad sagt allen, hallo, hier bin ich, benutzt mich. Das Mausrad rotiert. Aber dann geht trotzdem der Pfeil rüber zur Scrollbar und dann wird runtergescrollt und die Mail beantwortet kurz. Und dann, das ist ein kleiner Sketch gewesen, das ist bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, die Mühlen oft langsam malen dann doch. Aber das Konzept liegt auf dem Tisch, Auge zu und durch, unsere Zyklopensitcom leider aktuell noch, ja, Anruf pending, sagen wir mal. Ja, Titel auch pending, ich würde sagen, lass es unter zwei Augen besprechen, lass das mal unter zwei Augen besprechen. Lass uns mal unter zwei Augen. Also wirklich ein Wort. Lass uns das erstmal unter zwei Augen besprechen.
Ja, aber was genau ist für dich das innere Auge, das interessiert mich jetzt schon, weil das ist ein Begriff.
Ich hatte das irgendwie.
Du warst in Kolumbien, du hattest eine spirituelle Erweckung, das haben wir alle mitbekommen, du bist auf einem spirituellen Weg.
Ich habe ja schon, Spoiler Alarm, gesagt, dass der Weg dich in dein Inneres führt, aber du warst ja immer Bergblume, Bergblume, Bergblume, von deinem Leben oder von der letzten Folge? Nein, von deinem spirituellen Lebensweg. So ein Hälser, der sagt Spoiler, aber sie werden ihre Liebste finden. Spoiler. Ja Und deswegen, hast du das innere Auge gefunden? Sagt man das nicht? Ich komme mir jetzt gerade selber bescheuert vor. Erklär es mir doch mal, was genau soll das denn sein? Ja, ich habe es mal aufgeschnappt. Beschreib es mal mit eigenen Worten. Also in welchem Kontext? Die Doku, die du gestern gesehen hast, worum ging es da? I don't fucking know! Aber benutze es doch mal in einem Satz. Also wie würdest du das benutzen, das innere Auge? Zum Beispiel, ein Satz wäre zum Beispiel, was ist das innere Auge? Nein, ich meine jetzt, okay, gut, in einem alternativen Satz, in einem Aussagesatz. Beschreib mir mal, was das innere Auge ist. Nein, also in irgendeinem Satz, was uns mehr über die Natur des Begriffs sagt. Ah, okay. Das innere Auge lässt mich auf mich hören, würde ich vielleicht sagen. Lässt mich auf mich hören. Vor allem, man nimmt das Auge und nimmt einen anderen Sinn, um zu beschreiben, was es aussieht. Hör auf dein inneres Auge. Genau, ein Satz, um es zu beschreiben, hör mal häufiger auf dein inneres Auge. Ah, okay, ich verstehe. Gut. Fühle mit deinem inneren Auge. Okay, verstehe. Wenn es darum geht, dass man sozusagen, man wird etwas gefragt. Wir neigen ja alle dazu, den Leuten um uns herum gefallen zu wollen. Und ich glaube, wenn man mal häufiger auf sein inneres Auge hört oder mal genauer fühlt, was das innere Auge einem sagt, dann finde ich, hat man guten Zugang zu sich selber. Dann guckt man nämlich eher mal auf sich. Was will ich eigentlich? Will ich gerade das, was die Leute machen? Will ich denen nur gefallen oder will ich eigentlich lieber zuhause nichts machen, um in Tiefkühlpizza ein TKP reinballern? Aber wo guckt das Auge hin? Also guckt es so nach vorne oder nach hinten? Es guckt gelangweilt aus dem Bauch aus. Nach vorne. So wie dieser Turtles-Boss, der immer noch so ein Wesen im Bauch hat. Der guckt immer nach vorne raus. Ich setze mir vor wie, es ist so in der Innenseite der Stirn und guckt nach innen aufs Hirn. Guckt nach innen aufs Hirn, okay, alles klar. Und dann ist es eine Art Selbstbetrachtung. Selbstbetrachtung. Ich kenne nur dieses Man sieht nur mit dem Herzen gut.
Man sieht nur mit dem Herzen recht. Recht? Nee, die wichtigsten Dinge sind für das Auge unsichtbar, man sieht sie nur herrlich mit dem Herz. Genau. Ich bin kein Sprichworttyp. Nee, aber Heinrich Heine. Ich musste sehr drüber lachen, weil wir haben letzte Woche oder vorletzte, so genau kriege ich das jetzt nicht mehr hierhin, entschuldigt das bitte, aber haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass wir als Kinder oft an dieses Problem gekommen sind, dass wir bei Hörspielen, Kassetten, was auch immer, klassischen drei Fragezeichen, TKKG, Höradventures, manche Wörter nicht verstanden haben. Und man hat natürlich dieses Kopfkino, dieses sehr reale Kopfkino und will wissen, wo etwas passiert und man ist sehr drin in der Welt. Und dann hatten wir die Beispiele Hain, Unterholz, Verschlag oder Lichtung, wo man sich fragt, wo sind sie gerade? Und das hat bei euch regen Anklang gefunden und ihr kennt das Problem auch, hat mich sehr gefreut. Hier zum Beispiel schreibt, der TikTok-User
Amon schreibt,
das ging mir beim Hörspiel zu Rennschwein Rudi
Rüssel so, da wird im Nebensatz was
vom Schweinemäster erzählt, der die ganze
Geschichte nicht vorkam.
Schweinemäster.
Ja.
Wenn man sich auch fragt, was...
Schweinemäster, ja. Und es ist ja wichtig,
anscheinend für die Story, ich finde es auch
irritierend, dass bei Rennschwein Rudi Rüssel dem Kinderhörspiel
Vielen Dank. Ja. Man sich auch fragt, was... Schweinemäster, ja. Und es ist ja wichtig, anscheinend für die Story. Ja, klar. Ich finde es auch irritierend, dass bei Rennschwein Rudi Rüssel im Kinderhörspiel Schweinemäster vorkommt. Naja, aber der ist ja der Koch, oder nicht? Naja. Also der ist ja für das Schwein, ist ja der Mäster das Nah. Du bist das Berater zu ihm. Der ist ja dem Nah. Naja, in gewisser Weise, oder? Ich meine, als Schwein willst du doch den Mäster, ist doch dein bester Freund. Du weisst ja nicht, warum du gemästet wirst. Ah ja. Du weisst, das ist ja wie so die Oma, die sagt, ach jetzt ist das noch auf. Menschenmäster. Genau, das ist ein Menschenmäster. Altdeutsche Oma. Im Grunde. Und du weisst ja nicht, wofür du gemästet wirst. Aber Mästen ist ja für. Das ist das Thema von Rennschwein, Rudi Rösse. Rudi Rösse. Purswissen Rennschwein. Ja. Das lebt ja nach so einem Sportkoch, der sagt, ach, es wird eine Ernährung, du kriegst einen Geriessbrei und dann war's das. Du wirst also mit Proteinriegeln gemästet oder so, also da musst du halt immer gucken, dass da auch irgendwie dann schon Eigelb und so. Das geht mir zu schnell. Na, weil das ist, die Geschichte von Rudi Rüssel ist ja, wie kriegst du ein Schwein, das einerseits schnell rennen kann, aber trotzdem herzhaft fettsaftig ist. Schmeckt, schmeckt. Gut schmeckt am Ende. Okay. Und am Ende. Die Synthese aus beidem. Richtig. Das ist die Charakterentwicklung. Es beginnt als Rennschwein, endet Safi auf dem Teller. Richtig. Und du hast diesen Konflikt, diesen inneren Konflikt, dieses ich will gewinnen, und dann, wie du es gesagt hast, ich will aber auch meinen Job als Schwein erfüllen, so die Erwartungen des Bauern, des Mesters erfüllen und so. Und dann musst du halt am Ende, rennt Rudi Rüssel als Erster durchs Ziel und springt quasi direkt ... Ins Feuer. Ins Feuer, in die Fritteuse und am Ende über einen Abspann und dann die, genau, whatever, whatever läuft, ist so ein drehender Spieß mit so einem mit so einem Apfel, aber so ein glücklich seliges Grinsen im Gesicht von Rudi. Und das Spanferkel hat so eine Goldmedaille um den Hals. Genau. Und die dreht sich so mit. Die dreht sich so mit, aber verhakt sich dann, weil es nicht ganz gut aufgehängt ist und nicht so mitgeht. Dann fällt die sich auf und dann immer wieder runter. Genau. Und es nervt ein bisschen. Es nervt ein bisschen, aber da merkt man, dass es kein Loop ist, sondern dass die wirklichste Spanferkel. Und dass das Budget nicht so hoch war. Nee, das stimmt. Aber genau, okay, das ist die Synthese. Sie konnten sich Shakira leisten. Also ich meine, da ist schon mal ein bisschen Geld reingefroschen. Also ich denke, er hätte nicht mehr Geld in was anderes fliessen sollen, zum Beispiel Ausstattung als jetzt oder die Handpuppe von Rudi Rüssel. Das merkt man auch erst nach dem Dreh. Natürlich, nach dem Dreh denkt man, fuck, ist das schon mal passiert in der Geschichte des Films, dass ein Regisseur den Film Dreharbeiten beendet hat und merkte, Alter, wir haben noch 160 Millionen Dollar übrig. Steck ich mir schön ein. Also, hör, hör, hör auf.
Steck ich mir schön ein?
Hä, nee.
Wir sitzen im Schnittraum, Regisseur und Editor und so.
Mit dem können wir uns nicht einschicken.
Wir können uns nicht einfach teilen.
Oder, oder, andere Idee, wir kaufen uns Whenever, Wherever von Shakira.
Von Shakira fürs Ende, geil.
Weil der kostet, habe ich gerade nachgeschaut, genau 160 Millionen. Perfekt, perfekt.
Weil es ist ja wirklich objektiv der beste Song, der jemals geschrieben wurde. Ist ja ganz klar. Ja. So, dann Marius kommentiert, da muss ich sehr lachen, weil ich das genau verstehe, was du meinst, er wusste nie, was Lippenschürzen heisst. Und Justus von die drei Fragezeichen hat so oft seine Lippen geschürzt. Wirklich? Wie oft kann man in einem Hörspiel die Lippen schürzen? Ist das ein Rekord? Ja, ey, Justus, hör auf, deine Lippen zu schürzen!
Nee, das ist Kussmund machen.
Aber es ist dieses Put your lips away, diese omnipräsente Geste, die man für alles nutzen kann.
Wenn dir jemand sagt, meine Tante ist gestorben, dann ziehst du die Lippen ein. Disappearing Lips. Ja, die Lippen sind ja das erotischste Organ des Menschen. Das heisst, in sensiblen Situationen ist es nur angebracht, die Lippen in den Mund hineinzusaugen. Also das hilft auch ein bisschen Gegendruck. Genau, es ist ja quasi wie das Genital. Das Genital hast du ja quasi ständig bedeckt. Draußen hängen. Nein, nein, nein. Stopp, lass mich kurz mal ausreden. Das Genital hast du ja gerade bedeckt den ganzen Tag, aber sozusagen die Sekundärgenitalien, die Lippen sind ja präsent für alle zu sehen, zu schmatzen und alles. Und in sensiblen Situationen müssen die dann mal eingepackt werden. Genau wie man ja nicht sein Genital auspacken würde, muss man
die Lippen einpacken.
Deswegen sieht man in Beerdigungen auch oft dann
diesen Moment, wo der Pfarrer dann sagt, wir haben uns heute versammelt
und bei allen so
bei allen gehen die Lippen so rein.
Kein Sauerstoff mehr im Raum, weil alle
so, ich hab, also okay, dann wäre das
Theorie eins. Aber was ist die
Schützung für dich? Theorie eins wäre
Lippen verschwinden lassen, die Disappearing Lips. Zwei wäre für mich, was du gerade als Anfang gemacht hast, der Kussmund. Also dieses Nachdenkende, die Stromberg-Schnute, wie ich sie nenne. Ja gut, das, also das, dieses Nachdenken, Kinn in die Höhe, Nachdenken, das oder was ich da genau das Nachdenken.
Aber was genau ist denn eine Schürze? Ja, pass auf, oder drei wäre bei mir so ein, so ein, ich weiss nicht, will man was sagen, aber man hat noch nichts verrat. Die Lippen sprechen, aber der Mund nicht. Aber ich weiss nicht, Schürze, also eine Schürze ist ja ein Schutz. Ah, vielleicht ist es das. Ich mache es kurz für unsere Patreon-User. Ah, die Unterlippe zieht sich über die Oberlippe. Ja, genau. Es gibt ja noch dieses Lippenkrempel, dass die Unterlippe so nach vorne umkrempelt. Genau, das kann man auch machen, wenn eine Tante gestorben ist. Das ist ganz normal und auch angebracht. Das ist dann wieder sozusagen Erotik plus. Also das ist dann sehr erotisch, wenn du dann sozusagen noch mehr von der Innenlippe zeigst. Okay, er macht's mehr auf Dates, Lippenschürzen. Ah, okay. Die hast du ja schon ewig nie mehr gemacht. Also, ich hab's herausgefunden. Also, einen geschürzte Lippeneffekt erreicht man, indem man Ober und jetztlippe leicht nach oben aussen stülpt und eventuell kräuselt.
Oben aussen stülpt?
Ja, nach aussen stülpt. Also in Trump.
Dieser Kussmund kann rechts oder links lastig sein. Der Amorbogen, oh ich erinnere, dass da noch ein Fremdwort auftaucht in dieser Erklärung, der Amorbogen befindet sich also nicht mehr in der Mitte. Ah, das ist das unter der Nase, unter dem Nasenbügel. Ein oft muffiger oder hochmütiger Eindruck. Muffig. Das muss ich muffig googeln. Muffig. Was ist denn muffig? Ich dachte, muffig ist so ein stehender Geruch, wenn es so ein bisschen muffig riecht. Ich finde, Erklärungstexte sollten nicht Wörter wie muffig beinhalten. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Oder dann direkt weiter verlinken, dass du wirklich durch eine unendliche Definitionskette dich einfach einmal im grossen Kreis drehst und dann wieder am Anfang bist. Buckface eigentlich. Aber es ist auch so ein ja, okay, mach mal. Wir bräuchten jetzt halt mal ein Beispiel, wie das bei die drei Fragezeichen dann tatsächlich genutzt wird, die Lippen-Schürzen. Aber ich check nicht, was genau die Schürze ist, also ist eine Schürze auch was so Ziehharmonika-mässig dann so gekräuselt, glaube ich, war das Wort. Eben Beispielbild, angehängt. Das ist kein natürlicher Ausdruck. Dann ist das Gegenteil angehängt als Bild. Ja, genau. Da waren wir auch schon. Lippen verstecken. Und dann ist hier noch ein Bild von einer Frau, die dieses wissende, hochmütige ja dann, da machen die Augenbrauen aber nicht mehr als der Mund, Smirk. Ja, interessant, wir haben es nicht geklärt und ich glaube, dass die Wortehrkunft nicht die Schürze ist, wie wir sie kennen. Schwierig, muss man das in einem Hörspiel wirklich, was die Leute machen, lass ihr noch was sagen. Also anstatt einfach den Erzähler zu sagen, Justus Jonas schürzte die Lippen, lass ihn noch sagen, hei da daus, das ist aber eine ganz schön unerwartete Wendung im Fall gewesen.
Ich habe noch wirklich, glaube ich, keine einzige Folge der drei Fragezeichen.
Die merkt man gar nicht. Justus Jonas schürzte lasziv die Lippen.
Und dann so, ja, Johann Ulbricht im Tonstudio, da bräuchten wir jetzt einmal einen Sound bitte. Kannst du einmal die Lippen schürzen? Kannst du einmal bitte die Lippen schürzen? Wir bräuchten es ein bisschen lauter. Nochmal einmal lauter bitte. Okay, perfekt. bei so einem erotikerspiel hatte ich exakt tatsächlich genau die situation tatsächlich
schon mal dass der manchmal in so serien oder Filmen oder irgendwas brauchst du ja ADR, Additional Dialogue Recording. Und wenn irgendwie, oft ist es, wenn irgendwie eine Requisite so geknistert hat oder man sich eine Jacke anzieht. Oder ein Helikopter über den Himmel fliegt. Sowas. Und währenddessen sagt man einen Satz, während man sich die Jacke anzieht und im Nachhinein stellt man sich raus, man versteht den Satz gar nicht. Dann muss man ihn nochmal sagen und da steht dann so ganz merkwürdiges Skript mit so ganz komischen Halbsätzen oder einzelnen Wörtern und da stand halt auch einfach Lächeln, also als Regierinweisung Lächeln und das war dann so. Ich glaube, wir haben das sogar zusammen aufgenommen, kann das sein? Stimmt, das kann sein, ja. Ja, und dann, was man erwartet davon ist immer, weil ich habe auch diese Listen geschrieben aus dem Schnitt und es ist immer so, wenn man sowas braucht für den Ton, weil nicht ganz klar deine Emotion nicht ganz klar ist oder so oder Ton oder halt die Amsel, die komischerweise immer dann kräht, wenn du deinen Mund aufmachst und man ja und ich glaube, es ist so ein, ist oft ist dann gemeint, ein Lächeln. Das ist dann immer sehr natürlich und toll und man denkt sich, ah geil, hier goes the Oscar for best tone. Man darf sich nicht zu viel damit beschäftigen, weil das macht einen wirklich Filme und Serien einfach kaputt. Weil irgendwann hört man ADR einfach immer raus und das kann man es nicht geniessen, weil dann muss ich jedem im Kino sagen, Entschuldigung, ADR steht für Additional Dialogue Recording and it's a tool used by filmmakers.
Das muss ich einfach jedem einzelnen sagen. Ja, man hört darauf.
Ich bin gerade in Hamburg angekommen und ich bin aus und zu gestiegen und das ist die ungekürzte Version.
Ich laufe, laufe, laufe und dann merke ich mir hat gerade eine taube auf den kopf geschissen es war genau ich kam in hamburg an hamburg gesagt hallo und habe ich wirklich und es war ich dachte ja dass was passiert nicht weil die chance ist ja denkbar gering weil es ist nicht auf nichts von mir gelandet nicht auf meiner meiner Jacke, nicht auf meinem Kopf oder so, nicht auf meinem Gesicht oder sowas, sondern wirklich einfach nur auf meinen Kopf, wie in dem Kinderbuch, wer hat den Maulwurf auf den Kopf gemacht, genau, auf den Kopf geschissen, oder wie das klingt. Du hingegen warst relativ schnell beim verdächtigen Taube, sind wir uns sicher darüber, dass der Täter tatsächlich, ist der Täter Taube? Täter ist nicht unbedingt Taube, aber Täter ist beflügelt. Kann der Täter Möwe sein? Täter kann Möwe sein. Hast du das Exkement noch? Ich habe es draufgefasst auf meinen Kopf und hatte dann wirklich diese braune Scheisse in der Hand, diese flüssige braune Dünsche. Das war Vögel ja immer die ganze Zeit Durchfall. Das stimmt. Muss man ja auch mal ganz klar sagen. Die essen ja Körner, ne? Also die essen ja das härteste, was es gibt. Tauben essen das Gegenteil von Körnern. Immer wenn ich so einen Knödel mache für die Vögel, dann ist es nur Körn. Das stimmt, aber das sind auch andere Vögel, meine ich. Aber da gebe ich mich darauf fest. Ich glaube, dass Tauben ganz viel anderes Zeug essen. Bei Tauben, also so formuliert, es wundert mich bei Tauben nicht, dass sie Durchfall haben. Ja, weil die nur Müll essen. Gerade so die Hauptbahnhoftauben, glaube ich, das sind so die schlimmsten Tauben. Und dann habe ich auf den Kopf geschissen und ich fasse an und habe die Scheisse an der Hand, gehe dann zu so einem Dönermann und frage, kann ich ein Servierter haben, die lachen mich aus, gehen mir die Servierter. Und das war wirklich super eklig. Und das war, das war Minute eins in Hamburg, Minute zwei war ich stehen in der Bahn, bin dann an die Bahn gestiegen, ging sehr schnell, ich musste dann wieder aussteigen und dann hat mir ein Typ den Vogel gezeigt, nicht den Vogel, diese Bischergeste, weil ich im Weg stand, weil ich mit einem anderen Problem beschäftigt war. Also ein sehr vogellastiger Tag, dir wurde der Vogel gezeigt und ein Vogel hat dir mal gezeigt, wer hier eigentlich oben ist. Ja, das war, ich fühle mich so unwillkommen. Ja, du, Hamburg ist rau, ne, Hamburg ist ein raues Pflaster, ne, also du bist, da musst du dich eher, sag ich mal, einklimatisieren, ne. Wraggs, wie? Naja, du, das ist halt ein bisschen rauer, ist halt ein bisschen rauer das ist gefühl ich muss mir so irgendwie die das ist die hamburger reue das ist halt alles hier ein bisschen rau du das ist aber auch eine herzlichkeit na also da wirst du auch mal irgendwie als zur begrüssung ins gesicht geklatscht oder so das ist dann halt was nettes okay das ist dann so ein bisschen dieser urbane schick okay bisschen ja das ist nicht irgendwiesschen, Küsschen, sondern wenn man lieb hat, den verpasst man dann auch eine Ohrfeife. Ich habe das Gefühl, man muss sich irgendwie die Gunst der Stadt erkaufen. Durch so einen Kampf, einen Faustkampf am Hafen. Ja, absolut. So nackt gegen irgendeinen Seemann gewinnen. So ein klassischer weissblau gestreifter Seemann. Genau, die ganze Zeit steht er fertig mit diesen Händen voreinander, wo er eigentlich angreifbar aussieht, wenn man sich das vorhört. Diese Comic-Techen-Aufigkeit. Ja, genau, diese Popeye-Kampfhaltung eigentlich. Er hat so eine Pfeife im Mund und sagt irgendwas Unverständliches. Und den kann man heraus... Huch, den bring's er, du! Genau, und man denkt, hm, bitte? Den er, bring's er, du! Und dann, das ist die Aufforderung zum Kampf. Genau. Und dann, wenn man den besiegt in einem fairen Kampf, dann hat man die, hm, bitte? Und dann, das ist die Aufforderung zum Kampf. Und dann, wenn man den besiegt, in einem fairen Kampf, dann hat man die Gunst Hamburgs und dann wird einem weder auf den Kopf geschissen, noch zeigt einem jemand der Vogel. Vielleicht bist du ja nicht wirklich willkommen, das muss man auch sagen. Aber es ist schon nicht so ganz wahrscheinlich. Boah, er kam gerade viel zusammen. Das ist schon krass. Man konnte sich gar nicht um die eine Sache aufregen, weil dann direkt was anderes kam. Ja. Und jetzt fühle ich mich so benutzt. Ich finde, Vögel haben auch mit das ekelhafteste Exkrement, das es gibt. Also was Tiere angeht, also vor allem, ich fand es interessant, dass du Braun gesagt hast, weil ich habe es oft als weiss, so Fensterscheibe oder so ist ja oft weiss und das ist ja so dieses, man hat das Gefühl, da wird das halbe innere Organ irgendwie noch mit auchgeworfen. Da wird einfach so alles heraus, Blut drin, Gerinnsel, irgendwie alles mögliche. Das ist einfach richtig furchtbar. Bei den gesunden Tauben kommt dann nur noch Blut mit. Aber vor allem, warum hast du dir so herzhaft auf den Kopf gefasst, Frank? Ich dachte, Wasser. Also hast du nicht so reingedippt. Die Wasseridee, die Wasservermutung. Wer kennt es nicht? Die Wassertheorie. Du kriegst was oben auf Kopf, die Wasservermutung, und du glaubst erstmal einen grossen Tropfen Wasser. Also hast du nicht so reingedippt. Die Wasseridee, die Wasservermutung. Wer kennt es nicht?
Die Wassertheorie. Du kriegst was oben auf den Kopf, die Wasservermutung, und du glaubst erstmal, ein grosser Tropfen Wasser hat mich getroffen. Das ist eine Wasserbombe oder sowas. Nee, aber so ein grosser Tropfen Wasser. Es gibt ja Regen und dann gibt es so grosse Tropfen. Weißt du, was ich meine? Genau, wenn die Wolke sagt, ach weißt du was, ich habe jetzt, ich habe keine Zeit, Leute. Haut alles in einem grossen Tropfen raus. dann einfach die ganze Wolke so blub und einfach ein grosser Tropfen genau.
Das ist ein sehr seltenes Phänomen, aber wenn man das sieht, ist es auch sehr schön anzugucken. Es ist herrlich anzugucken. Nee, aber es sind eher diese Tropfen, die sich bilden an Bäumen und oder so, ich weiß nicht, Vorsprüngen, Dachvorsprüngen oder sowas.
Die sind grösser.
Und da bilden sich dann grosse Tropfen, ja, weil die sich sammeln. Und dann fallen die erst durch Gravitación hinunter oder herunter oder hinunter. Eins von beiden. Und dann dachte ich erst, die Wasservermutung, es wären Wassertropfen, hab aufgefasst und dann alles voller braunem Zeug. Das war nicht so schön. Gibt es wirklich Vögel, die braunen Kot haben? Ja. Weil ich überlege gerade, welche
anderen Tiere gibt es noch, die...
Wer hat Stefan auf den Kopf gemacht?
Das ist jetzt erstmal die Frage für die heutige Folge.
Und jetzt müssen wir zu verschiedenen Tieren gehen
und da mal fragen, weil ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Ich dachte, das wäre immer weiss.
Es war so brauner,
länglich-wurmmässig
braun
und sehr, sehr dünnflüssig braun-grün, so ins Kaki rein. Nein, hey! Ja, ins Kaki. Wir haben eine neue Regel. Tut mir leid, wir haben eine neue Regel. Ach so, ich muss die Mail vorlesen. Ja, eine neue Regel. Wenn eine Mail kommt und die Aufnahme stört, dann muss derjenige die vorlesen. Lidl-Gewinner. Oh. Florentin, bitte bestätigen Sie den Empfang.
Beeil dich, die Anzahl der zu gewinnenden Preise ist begrenzt.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Sie wurden ausgewählt an unserem Treueprogramm für Teilnehmer kostenlos.
Es dauert nur eine Minute, bis Sie diesen fantastischen Preis erhalten.
Monsieur.
Was für ein Preis.
Monsieur Cuisine Connect.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Mein Preis.
Der Preis ist, du darfst beim Treueprogramm mitmachen? Nein, mein Preis ist der Monsieur Cuisine Connect. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Der Preis ist, du darfst beim Treueprogramm mitmachen?
Nein, mein Preis ist der Monsieur Cuisine Connect.
Den kriege ich.
Aber das neuste Modell.
Also das ist jetzt hier kein Quatsch.
Ja.
Okay.
Soll ich da drauf tippen, oder?
Ja, tipp mal drauf, das ist glaube ich immer gut.
Jetzt bestätigen.
Ich glaube, man soll drauf tippen.
Das ist gar kein Knopf. Letztens hat eine Nachbarin bei mir geklingelt und hat mir so ihr Handy gezeigt und meinte, ich habe da so eine Nachricht bekommen, dass ein DHL-Paket abgegeben wurde und sie haben ja unten geschrieben, dass bei ihnen ein Paket nicht ankam. Und das sind einfach so Betrüger-Nachrichten. Also einfach so ihr DHL-Nachricht, ihr DHL, wir konnten ihre Adresse nicht bestätigen, bitte klicken Sie auf den Link. Und dann habe ich gesagt, nein, nein, das ist nicht echt, das ist Betrug. Und dann meinte sie, ja, ja, ja, das weiss ich schon, das habe ich gelesen. Ich meine, ich dachte nur, falls die Betrüger vielleicht genau ihr Paket haben. Was hat sie verstanden? Und was hat sie nicht verstanden? Genau, ja das ist genau ... Wo hört sie auf, an Betrug zu glauben? Was glaubt sie, ist das für ein Betrug? Und es war so niedlich irgendwie so, ja ich weiss schon, aber das ist so. Wo hört ihr Wissen auf? Ich hätte es wirklich gerne gefragt. Okay, erklären Sie mir bitte jetzt von Anfang an, wie funktioniert es so gut. Erklären Sie mir die Welt. Erklären Sie mir, wie Sie die Welt wahrnehmen. Oh, ich fand das so süß. Sie kriegt diese Nachricht. Ja, ja, ich weiss das schon. Das ist ja grossartig. Aber davor habe ich grosse Angst vor sowas. Ich habe grosse Angst, weil man ja manchmal zur Arroganz tendiert, wenn man glaubt, etwas zu wissen und oft so, ja, ich weiss schon, was du meinst und dann sagt man was Falsches. Genau. Ist natürlich das schlimmste, was dir passiert. Das allerschlimmste, ja. Das grösste Ei, was du dir rhetorisch legen kannst. Absolut, ja. Und tatsächlich habe ich auch daran gedacht, weil da gab es letztens auch eine Last Week Tonight Folge drüber.
Ich glaube, so Piggy, irgendwas mit Pig, Pig Feeding oder irgendwie heisst es, dass du irgendeinen so naiven Trottel fütterst du dir an und dann am Ende sagst du ja, ich brauche 1000 Euro für den Flug oder bla bla bla und dann nimmst du den aus so. Und da kam mir dann wieder in Erinnerung, dass ich ja hier in meinem Podcast erzählt habe, Stefan, hey, ich muss dir was erzählen, ich habe eine total lustige Nachricht bekommen, und zwar hieß es, Stefan, hast du die Hot, bist du der Besitzer von Hotpot?
Stimmt, ja, ja, der Hotpot.
Es gab dieses Hotpot-Ding.
Ja, genau.
Und da hat mir jemand eine Nachricht geschrieben, hey, Stefan.
Florentin.
Nee, das ist nett von dir, das weiss ich schon, ähm, nein, aber in der Nachricht gibt es...
Solche Momente meine ich dieses, ah, du hast dich versprochen, und dann sagt man was Falsches.
Das meine ich genau, was ich gerade meinte.
Ne, und deswegen bin ich auch...
Das weiss ich.
Deswegen bin ich auch darauf reingefallen, weil ich, weil ich dachte, ah, Stefan, irgendjemand entweder hat verwechselt mich oder hat mich gegoogelt oder irgendwas und hat irgendwas hart missverstanden oder irgendwas. Deswegen bin ich angesprochen und darauf bauen die ja, dass die von zehn Millionen Nachrichten halt irgendwo mal zufällig was treffen, wo Leute denken, okay, das kann kein Zufall sein. Aber Stefan ist ja nicht der häufigste Name. Ich weiss es nicht genau, aber es ist ja vielleicht der naivste Name. Also es kann nicht jetzt gar nicht unbedingt jetzt gehen was gegen dich, es gibt ja viele, aber vielleicht hat man einfach überlegt, okay, wir wollen betrügen, was ist der naivste, dümmste, dümmlichste, also sozusagen der leichtgläubigste. Nee, nee, weil das klingt halt ein bisschen beleidigend. Also ich verstehe, du sagst, du meinst es nicht so, du hast ja explizit vorangestellt, dass es nicht beleidigend meint, nur weil es einfach so klingt. Nee, aber die haben wahrscheinlich überlegt, welcher Name ist einerseits reich, wohlhabend, erfolgreich, aber hat gleichsam ein hohes Mass an Dummheit, Naivität. Das meine ich, das ist der Punkt, der mich beleidigt hat. Nein, du willst ja keinen dummen Armen als Opfer haben. Du willst ja dumme, reiche, dumme, guter Aussehende, erfolgreiche, wirklich im Leben stehende Menschen, die aber gleichzeitig so dumm sind, ihr Reichtum wegzugeben. So, und deswegen bin ich darauf eingefallen und jetzt habe ich mich auch ein bisschen dumm gefühlt, weil wahrscheinlich diese Folge und schreibt uns da gerne, gern, als diese Folge geärrt ist, haben wahrscheinlich viele Leute mit wirklich steinernster Miene diese Geschichte sich angehört und gesagt, Steiner haben einen komischen Ruf. Für Dinge, die kein Gesicht haben, das wie die, auch Bier. Ich glaube, ich glaube, Steiner ernst ist kein, is not a thing. Ich glaube, Steiner ernst ist mit steinerer Miene, glaube ich, wollte ich sagen. Haben die den Podcast angehörter, haben leise nur vor sich hingehaucht. Das ist Betrug. Das ist Betrug. Ich musste sehr lachen, weil du bist nicht so bescheuert, wie du tust. Beziehungsweise wir haben ja mal damals vor unendlich vielen Folgen gesagt, These, Algorithmen sind eine Horde Inder. Genau. Und Horde ist nicht abwertend gemeint. Horde ist einfach nur eine viele, ein unüberblickbarer Haufen. Ja, und jetzt heute, gerade heute, 3. April, ich verrate euch, wann wir aufnehmen, kam raus, 11.49 Uhr, NTV schreibt, hinter Amazon KI stecken tausend Inder. Ich mag auch, dass dieser Begriff tausend Inder einfach so ein geflügeltes Wort geworden ist. Weil es waren ja nie im Leben genau tausend. Nee. Weißt du, was ich... Nein, warum stellt euch mal tausend Inder vor? Und jetzt... Also stellt euch mal vor, wie viele Leute waren in eurer Schulklasse.
Stellt euch mal den Raum vor, wie gross der Wärme tausend Inder. Das kann man ja, um sich vorzustellen, wie weit die Erde von der Sonne entfernt ist.
Stellt euch mal tausend Inder vor und nehmt das ganze mal neunhundert.
So, Einkauf ohne Kassen hinter Amazon KI stecken tausend Inder.
Amazon zieht bei seiner angeblich revolutionären Supermarkttechnologie die Reisleine.
Da habe ich auch immer nicht verstanden, die Reisleine ziehen. Zusätzlich zu einer KI sollen mehr als tausend manuelle Prüfer in Indien einen Einkauf ohne Kassen ermöglicht haben.
Nun setzt der Konzern auf vernetzte Einkaufswagen als Alternative. Also da war eine Kamera drin, von wegen Scan, hat dann Inder gesessen und gesagt, Banane, piep, hat im Mikrofon piep gesprochen, glaube ich, und dann war der Einkauf fertig. Ah, okay, also die haben gesagt, wir machen ein Foto von einem Einkauf und sagen dir, was drin ist im Korb, aber eigentlich wurde das nur dem Inder vorgelegt, ausgedruckt. Unsere Self-Checkout-Kassen bei Rewe sind nicht intelligent, sondern es sind vier Inder. Einer, der guckt, ob man das hinlegt, einer, der sich anguckt, sind es Bananen, was ist es genau, der die Barcodes auswendig kennt, der dritte, sie hat einen Taschenrechner in der Hand, so einen alten, so einen Casio-Taschenrechner und tippt ganz schnell die Summen ein und der Letzte nimmt die Karte entgegen, wenn man die reinschiebt.
Und wechseln die auch mal? Nie, niemals. Die sind wirklich für diesen genauen Zweck ausgebildet worden und bleiben auch ihr ganzes Leben an genau dieser Stelle. Ja, hat niemand gesagt, dass das eine schöne Geschichte ist. Ne, das ist krass, vor allem, dass es sich lohnt, dass du einfach sagen kannst, ich zahl tausend Gehälter anstatt so ein Dings, also ich meine, mit JavaScript programmier ich dir das Ding, also das ist nicht so aufwendig. Okay, sag mal eine Zeile von JavaScript. Naja, if, banana, then, irgendeine Zahl, one. Aber wie teuer ist eine Banane? Wie teuer sind gerade Bananen?
Naja, da hast du ja eine Datenbank hinter.
Ich möchte dich gerade fragen, einfach als Konsumenten Florentin will, wie teuer ist gerade eine Banane? 70 Cent? Ja, weiss ich nicht. Ich weiss immer nicht genau, wann man Bananen kaufen soll, weil die, also eigentlich bräuchtest du ja so ein, so ein, so ein komplettes Spektrum an Bananen, damit du jeden Tag die perfekte Banane hast. Aber jetzt ist, was Merkwürdiges passiert bei mir zu Hause, eine grüne Banane ist schlecht. Also die hat so geskippt. What? So, das ist so ganz merkwürdig. Das ist so wie wenn du ein Kind mit einem Rollator siehst. Ein Kind mit Falten. Das ergibt keinen Sinn. Ja, genau. Wenn du ein altes Kind siehst. Ein Kind, was zu dir sagt, nee, ich dachte, die Betrüger haben vielleicht genau ihr Paket. Nee, das ist so ganz merkwürdig, weil du denkst, irgendwas läuft hier richtig falsch. Das ist ja so merkwürdig. Einfach komplett geskippt. Krankheit. Kann gut sein. Die Bananenkrankheit. Bananenparasit. Ja, die sah nicht gut aus. Die war wirklich so ganz gekrümmt, sah die schon aus. Ja, ich fand es großartig. Vielen Dank an unseren Reddit-User. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den sagen soll. Complex Extent. Ohne jetzt zu viel vorwegzugeben. Dafür hast du dir Sorgen gemacht, das hast du schon aber sehr abfällig. Ja, ich meine nur... Ich weiss nicht, ob wir jetzt den Namen sagen können, ja, Complex Extend Destiny. Ja, da ist doch eine Zahl drin, die will ich jetzt nicht. 5, 4, 6, 8, ja, so wahr. Und dann genau Mühe geben, den aber genau zu benennen. Nicht weil sie aber genannt werden will, aber er steht ja offensichtlich mit seinem Klarnamen. Ja, Dank an Komplex für dieses Bild. Wo wir gerade dabei sind. Wir haben ja letztens einen Aufruf gemacht und jemand hat uns geschrieben. Ich weiss nicht mehr. Stefan, willst du es kurz einleiten? Nein, ich weiss nicht, welcher Aufruf. Wir machen ja immer was. Wir haben eine Aktion gestartet. Ja, ja, wahrscheinlich mehrere sogar in den letzten paar Folgen. Eine ganz konkrete, dass wir was machen für unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer. Genau. Und das möchte Florentin jetzt mal vorstellen. Was war das denn? Das ist nicht mehr. Tu jetzt nicht so, als ob du das noch wüsstest. Okay. Du kriegst nur die ganzen Mails immer und dann bist du erinnert an die Folge. Hallo, ich habe heute gehört, dass wir eventuell einen Strafzettel übernehmen, wenn man bei Blitzen Podcast hört. Ja, super. Hier die Story, ich bin mit meiner Oma zurück nach Hause mit meinem Sohn gefahren. Ich bin mit meiner Oma zurück nach Hause mit meinem Sohn gefahren. Warum hat der Sohn es ans Ende des Satzes geschafft und die Oma ganz am Anfang? Es ist merkwürdig, warum sagt er nicht, ich bin mit meiner Oma und Sohn, nein, ich bin mit meiner Oma zurück nach Hause mit meinem Sohn gefahren, mit meiner Frau. Dabei hat mein Sohn von meiner Oma, das ist so eine Christopher Nolan Exposition, ich kann dem nicht folgen. Ah, das wird so ein Deutsch-Lerrentext einfach so. Okay, die Schüler können vier Vokabeln, wie kriegen wir da jetzt einen Fies-Text hin? Oder so, am Ende ist es wie so, als wenn man Deutsch als Fremdsprache lernt und dann so, wer hat wem die Banane gegeben? A, der Sohn der Oma, B, die Oma dem Sohn. Also, ich glaube, er hat ein Bild vor Augen. Also, dabei hat mein Sohn meiner Oma eine Gießkanne geschenkt bekommen. Was? Er, drei Jahre alt, freute sich während der Fahrt sehr über seine neue Gießkanne und hat mich, vorne sitzend, etwas damit genervt. Wer fährt? Also Oma und Sohn hinten, Negiskan ist im Spiel, der Fahrer vorne. Damit etwas genervt. Leider habe ich dadurch irgendwie, vielleicht auch weil ich so in euren Podcast vertieft war, die Ausfahrt verpassen. Gieskanne, Oma, Podcast, Sohn. Und es ist Rätsel, es ist wie das Rätsel, man darf nur, weil Gießkanne und Podcast wiesen sich aus.
Die Oma sass neben dem, der die Gießkanne hatte und hinter dem, der den Podcast gehört hat. Die Oma hat aber nicht den Podcast gehört.
Also musste ich einen Umweg auf der Autobahn fahren. Doch dann wurde es etwas nerviger. Er hat mit mir der Oberseite der Gesskanne vollkommen in die Giesseile.
Warte. Ah, die Ohr. Also, stell mir die Kieskanne vor. Ich hab's blöd, ich war auch. Eieiei. Also, ohnehin schon nervige Situation, jetzt wird's noch nerviger. Also, er hat mit der Oberseite der Gieskanne vollkommen in die Seite gestochen, wodurch ich mich total erschreckt habe und die Spur unabsichtlich gewechselt habe. Ach du Scheiße.
Wie ich feststellen musste, war da aber ein Auto. Um dem auszuweichen … An der rechten Seite des Autos. Um dem auszuweichen, bin ich dann auf das Gaspedal getreten, denn es war nur eine Flucht nach vorne möglich. Doch bei dieser Flucht wurde ich mit einem roten Blitzen belohnt. Ich bin mir ganz sicher, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie viel zu schnell ich gefahren bin, denn ich habe noch keinen Brief erhalten. Aber dennoch wollte ich diesen Vorfall mit euch teilen. Und vielleicht erhören mich ja Tietze und Will Götter und ich bekomme eine Zuzahlung zu meinem Strafzettel. Liebe Grüße, Michael. Michael, wir stehen hier in der Verantwortung, ganz, ganz klar. Also es gibt verschiedenste, erstmal grossartig. Ich finde es toll, dass du deinen Lieblingspodcast, das Podcast-Ufo, hörst, während sowohl Oma als auch Enkel als auch Gießkanne mit der Oberseite im Auto sind. Das finde ich schon mal fantastisch, weil das machen nicht viele, also mit Oma und Kind im Auto. Nee, das ist schon gut.
Den Podcast zu hören. Das ist ein treuer Fan. Ich möchte auch die, ich habe viele Fragen an die Oma. Sehr viele Fragen. Ich habe weniger Fragen an die Gieskanne, weil die scheinen eher so Mittel zum Zweck zu sein. Ja, das ist halt so ein bisschen der MacGuffin der Geschichte, habe ich das Gefühl. Nützlich, aber jetzt nicht so relevant. Grossartig. Ich würde sagen, Michael, auf jeden Fall, wir helfen dir hier weiter. Ja. Denn wir stehen hier in der Schuld. Klar, es gibt verschiedenste Schuldparteien in diesem Konglomerat.
Genau.
Ich sehe hier natürlich auch die Oma in Verantwortung.
Weil sie auf das Kind hätte aufpassen sollen, weil sie sass ja vor demjenigen.
Ja, so ganz habe ich jetzt die Topografie des Autos nicht vor Augen, weil wenn das Kind hinter ihm sass mit der Oma und dann die Oberseite der Gießkanne ihm in die Seite. Nee, nicht ihm in die Seite oder gegen die Seite des Autos. Leider haben wir, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen Rechtschaltfähigkeiten. Er hat und jetzt Achtung, er hat mit mit der Oberseite der Gießkanne. Ich würde sagen, es heisst, er hat mir mit der Oberseite der Giesskanne vollkommen in die Seite gestochen. Ja, ja. Wobei, wodurch ich mich total erschrocken habe und die Spur unabsichtlich gewechselt habe. Ach du Schande, aber es klingt ein bisschen gefährlicher, es wäre gefährlicher, aber dass dann auch da ein Blitzer gerade ist. Aber also, warte mal. Ich glaube, du musst es nicht zahlen. Warte mal. Das muss man nicht zahlen. Ich glaube, es ist der Gieskeinparagraf, wo man relativ easy rauskommt mit Solmecke. Er wird getroffen, erschrockt, fährt nach links. Erschrockt. Erschrockt. Links, das Auto kommt näher. Er merkt, ich kann jetzt nicht mehr nach rechts fahren, sondern ich muss jetzt Gas geben, um in der Zeit, wo die Autos sich nähern, nach vorne zu kommen. Du bezeichnest mich ja gerade der Lüge. Nein, nein, ich versuch es mir nur, bitte nicht vorzustellen. Würde man nicht, wenn man aus Versehen die Spur wechselt und man merkt, oh, da ist ein Auto, nicht einfach wieder zurückfahren? Ist das nicht... Ich habe mir so vorgestellt, als ob er schon zu weit in der Spur drin war, er quasi eher einen Auffallunfall provoziert hätte. Du meinst, von hinten kam ein Auto schneller als er und deswegen musste er auch eher Gas geben. So was, okay. Vielleicht kann man das ja nachstellen, also vielleicht gibt es ja jemanden unter euch, der das irgendwie Storyboard-mässig uns mal vielleicht so ein bisschen vor Augen führen können, aber ich glaube, werden diesen fall bearbeiten wir werden uns darum kümmern und keine sorge michael wir haben das mitverschuldet und wir stehen natürlich für unsere verantwortung gerade sternchen wenn da mehr jetzt also wenn es so wenn wir so ich dachte jetzt eher so an 10 20 euro er sagt er weiss nicht ja gut aber vor allem auf der autobahn also ich meine ja aber es kann natürlich sein dass es irgendwie zwei punkte und alsoanzig Euro. Er sagt ja, er weiss nicht, ja gut, aber vor allem auf der Autobahn, also ich meine. Ja, aber es kann ja natürlich sein, dass es irgendwie zwei Punkte und 550 Euro sind oder sowas. Ne, aber wir wissen nicht genau, was dann, also durch den Schock der Gieskeine kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass da ein bisschen mehr Geschwindigkeit involviert war. Und dann möchte ich natürlich sagen, wir können jetzt was zuzahlen, aber wir können nicht die Podcast-UFO-Kassen leerräumen. Nee, das stimmt.
Wir brauchen noch so viel, brauchen wir für uns.
Vorhänge.
Oder für uns privat. Also wir brauchen noch so viel für uns privat.
Wir haben einen laufenden Rechtsstreit mit der Kirche Köln am Laufen, ob die nicht die Glocken vielleicht.
Der Kölner Kirchenkreis, kkk, mit denen haben wir eine Menge noch am Laufen.
Ob die nicht vielleicht, wir haben da einige Outfits gespendet und so, aber dass die vielleicht einfach die Glocke, Der Kölner Kirchenkreis, kkk, mit denen haben wir eine Menge noch am Laufen.
Vielleicht, wir haben da einige Outfits gespendet und so, aber das ist vielleicht einfach die Glocke ein bisschen. Aber da sind wir dran, da sind wir dran. Michael, schreibt uns, halt uns bitte auf dem Laufenden und wir werden uns da auf jeden Fall darum kümmern, denn wir haben auch eine Verantwortung für unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer, das ist klar. Ja, das ist ganz klar. In diesem Sinne, fahrt vorsichtig. Ja, fahrt vorsichtig und passt bitte auf, wenn ihr Kleinkindern Gießkanne schenkt, die Vorderseite, die Oberseite ist gefährlich. Kinder wünschen sich so random shit immer. Ich finde es ja sowieso geil, dass natürlich dieses Kind sofort das Waffenpotential der Gießkanne auch entdeckt hat. Also da brauchen ja Ingenieure Jahre dafür, um diese Gießkanne endlich mal als Waffe auch einsetzen zu können. Das Kind sofort, Messerscharf, Oberseite, Waffe in die Seite des Vaters, Feind erkannt, direkt so der Königsmord, Fahrer, verwundbar, direkt ich Nachfolger, Erbe, all das in der kurzen Zeit, sofort verstanden. Ich bin gerade Beifahrer. Genau, ich will nicht Beifahrer sein. Ich will lieber Fahrer sein. Und wenn ich den König gleich Fahrer erschlage, kann ich an dessen Stelle treten und das Auto sicher gen Frankreich fahren und dann mal gucken. Aber ich finde es auch gut, dass das Kind sich überlegt, erst den Vater, dann die Oma ausschalten. Der ist mit dem Stärksten. Wenn du erst die Oma ausschaltest. Dann hast du den Vater, der kann auch viel machen.
Der ist der Vater alarmiert.
Du schenkst ihm Zeit, zu reagieren.
Richtig. Und du kannst, dass er sich davor vorbereiten kann.
Wenn du den Überraschungsmoment nutzen willst, erst Vater ausschalten, dann vielleicht mit der Hinterseite der Gießkanne, Oma ausschalten und das Auto gehört dir.
Das Problem ist nur, wenn du erst den Fahrer ausschaltest, du kannst unmöglich vorhersehen, wie das Auto reagiert auf diesen Schlag. Ja, das stimmt. Ob es nach rechts geht. Oder woanders hin. Das können wir nicht vorher sagen. Das wissen wir nicht. Ja, schwierig, aber schöne Geschichte auf jeden Fall. Ja, vielen Dank, aber Leute, ey, das ist ganz schön gefährlich, was ihr da treibt.
Also ich stelle mir euch immer vor, wie ihr in so einem ganz weichen Sessel zu Hause sitzt, irgendwie so ein warmes Glas Nutella in der Hand und dann wirklich genüsslich die Podcast-Folge konsumiert, aber währenddessen einfach irgendwie mit 180 auf der Autobahn irgendwie angegriffen werden. Krass, Leute, ey, okay. Aber dieser Aufruf gefällt mir dann doch gut. Ich erinnere mich jetzt doch gut an die Folge und ich würde mir wünschen, dass wir mehr Einsendungen bekommen. Also ich würde das sogar so erweitern, falls durch unseren Podcast irgendwas bei euch im Leben schief geht, kaputt gegangen ist. Wir kommen dafür auf. Wir kommen dafür auf. Ohne Sternchen. Wir kommen dafür auf, wenn wir ursächlich sind, dass etwas im Haushalt kaputt gegangen ist. Euch fällt was runter. ihr habt irgendwie die falschen Medikamente genommen, weil wir das empfohlen haben, dann kommen wir dafür natürlich auf. Natürlich. Das ist ja klar. Da ist der Rechtsweg komplett offen. Der ist komplett, der komplette Kanal ist offen. Auf jeden Fall. Nur würde Thais sozusagen wie so eine Versicherungsprüferin bei euch auf der Matte stehen, wenn wir sie finden. Rest in Peace. Das müssen wir eh erst mal schaffen. Erst mal Thais finden. Genau, Thais, Rest in Peace, würde dann kommen und würde schauen, was passiert ist mit eurem Missgeschehen. Also als Sachbearbeiterin einfach dann wirklich das prüfen, weil bei so einer Sache, es ist leider die Welt, in der wir leben, wenn du so einen Aufruf machst, dann kommen natürlich auch viele, die irgendwelche hanebüchenen Fälle jetzt da sagen und ah, mir ist der Picasso runtergefallen. Das geht natürlich nicht.
Das geht natürlich nicht.
Und wir kennen euch.
Wir kennen eure Picassos. Wir wissen genau, was ihr für Menschen seid und was wir da wieder für Nachrichten kriegen. Mein Lamborghini, ich habe ihn an den Baum gesetzt. Ah, Leute, ihr seid so moradisch durchtrieben. Und wirklich, ihr seid auf einer Abwärtsspirale. Findest du? Dreht euch um, kommt wieder hoch. Komm wieder hoch, Podcast-Hörer! Komm wieder hoch, Podcast-Hörer! Habt ihr jetzt gar keine Musik mehr bei euch, nur noch die Stimme oder was? Also nur noch, hm, was machen denn Annen und Mai? Red mal lauter, Katharina! Was machen denn Annen Kanterheit eigentlich? Weil ich habe das Gefühl, die Songs bestehen nur noch aus Mai. Komm mal runter, Katharina! Okay, alles klar, ja, danke. Wenn er älter wird, ist wirklich, red mal lauter, Katharina, sprech mal deutlich. Ist das ein Sketch, Anne-Mein-Kantereit im Altersheim? Ja. Jetzt red mal lauter, Katharina, bring mir mal den Rollator. Auch der liegt als Pitch Paper vor Ort. Der Pfleger hat mich angezogen, ausgezogen. Gewaschen, angezogen, ausgezogen. Kinder haben mich nicht mehr angehufen. Bingo, bingo, Katharina!
Ja, gibt's bestimmt irgendwo jemanden, der Lust hat, das zu produzieren, falls ihr eine Kamera rumliegen habt. Wir wären da auf jeden Fall bereit. Weil wir sind es nicht. Wir haben gerne Ostern gefeiert. Das ist die grosse Osterfolge. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Die grosse Osterfolge. Wir haben es ein bisschen verpasst. Gehen wir zu. Wir haben es ein bisschen verpasst. Achso, sind wir gefeiert?
Ich habe es noch ein bisschen gefeiert.
Ist an uns vorbeigerauscht, irgendwas Buntes ist an uns vorbeigerannt und es gibt einen Trend, den ich immer skeptisch anziehe. Bemalte Eier. Wurde mir auch, nee, damit bin ich völlig d'accord. Bitte weitermachen. Okay, das klingt so, als ob du lieber bemalte Eier willst als unbemalte Eier. Falls ihr gerade einen Pinsel in der Hand habt, ein paar Eier im Haus, zögert ich. Zögert keine weitere Sekunde. Es gibt nichts, was auf euch aufhalten. Wieso? Farbverschwendung, Eiferschwendung. Kein Grund, überhaupt keinen Grund. Die Eier sind danach schöner, schmecken besser. Aber er wurde mir zugeschickt, weil ich habe mich ja schon beschwert, weil ich habe ja schon erspäht die Osterdominosteine. Das jetzt Osterdominosteine und ich habe gesagt, Moment, ist das nur ein billiger Trick von der Süssigkeitenindustrie? Du hast gesagt, halt Stopp, hört auf damit. Ich habe halt Stopp ausgesprochen, aber es geht ungehindert weiter. Und jetzt wurde mir tatsächlich zugesandt der Osterstollen. Stollen, die Kuchen, werden einfach verpackt und als Ostergebäck verkauft. Und ich sage, wo führt das hin? Nee, aber das erinnert mich an meine Oster-Experience, weil ich habe einen Osterkranz gekauft. Der sah aus wie ein Sankt-Martins-Kranz. Irgendjemand da draußen will einfach Weihnachten und Ostern verschmelzen, um alle Produkte doppelt benutzen zu können. Welche Kraft, welche machiavellische Kraft zieht
da im Hintergrund die Fäden, um zu sagen, das ist jetzt kein Ziel, was wir morgen oder übermorgen erreichen werden. Ja, mein Lord. Aber in zwei, drei Jahren, da werden die Menschen Weihnachten hören und nach Ostern denken. Mein Lord. Und sie werden, ja, halt mal die Karte. Oder sie werden Ostern hören und an Weihnachten. Mein Gott, denke ich einfacher, obwohl ich gar nichts zu sagen habe. Okay, alles gut, kein Problem. Hast du die Stollen bereit? Ja, mein Lord, ich wollte mich nur noch für den Vorfall entschuldigen, dass ich gesprochen habe, als sie gesprochen haben. Dann bemal sie und schick sie an Netto. Was steht da dahinter? Ich meine, jeder kennt den Trick, dass die Weihnachtsmänner dann einfach umgeschmolzen werden in Osterhasen. Da ist aber zumindest noch ein Schmelzprozess im Gange. Und für mich ist eine Schmelzung immer eine Art Reinigung. Okay? Ist für mich halt einfach so. Für diesen Satz möchte ich mich ganz weit distanzieren. Und dann möchte ich sagen, ist es nicht im Prinzip auch das gleiche Fest. Das eine ist nämlich Jesu Geburt. Ah, Doppelgeburt. Das andere ist Jesus, Jesus Auferstehung. Das ist gut, mein Knabe. Und ich glaube, das hängt ja schon irgendwie auch christlich mit zusammen. Beides ist das Lichtkorn auf die Erde oder den Himmel. Und deswegen haben wir doch vielleicht auch die gleichen Rituale verdient an diesen Festen.
Ich finde sogar, Ostern wird nicht
dafür, dass eigentlich das höchste christliche Fest
ist, nicht genug gefeiert.
Aber weißt du warum? Weil es keine Osterlieder gibt.
Bei Weihnachten hast du sofort irgendwie schon
Ende September irgendwas zu Last Christmas im Ohr
zu Ostern kein einziges Lied
und ich glaube die Menschen, ja aber
geh mal zu Ostern in den Supermarkt und
hör mal die
Leusch mal die Löffel. Leusch mal die Löffel und guck mal, ob du da irgendein Osterlied vernimmst. Osterhase, Osterhase, Osterhase, versteck die Eier, steck sie jedes, jedes Jahr. Gibt's nicht. Und deswegen glaube ich, meine These, meine Prognose, wir machen am Ende der Folge immer eine Prognose, meine Prognose für die Zukunft ist, erstens, dass wir jede Folge eine Prognose machen, zweitens glaube ich, dass auch die Weihnachtslieder umfun bist nicht nur zur Osterzeit, nein, auch im Winter, wenn es schneit. O Osterei, O Osterei, wie schön sind deine O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, O, so ein geiles Video, ich liebe ja Klaus Kauker, es ist ein YouTuber, der sich mit Musik beschäftigt.
Ist der im Kölner Kirchenkreis?
Ja, Klaus Kauker, genau, Köln, KKK, Klaus Kauker Köln, und er hat O, Tannenbaum die Geschichte untersucht, weil es ein mega merkwürdiger Song ist für Musiker, weil der halt gar kein Metrum hat, es ist so O, Tannenbaum, oh Tannenbaum, also man macht diese Pause nicht. Dadurch ist man so ein merkwürdiger, manche sind im Dreivierteltakt, manche sind im Viervierteltakt. Besinnlichkeit nenne ich das. Nee, es ist pures Chaos. Oh Tannenbaum ist pures Chaos. Niemand weiß, wo man anfangen soll, alle machen die Pausen anders, jeder singt es anders, wenn man es Leuten einfach nur A Cappella, Oh Tannenbaum gibt. Also ein ganz tolles Video, kann ich mir empfehlen. Dann nur auch mal eins, ein Tannenbaum hat keine Blätter. Wollte ich nur mal da in den Raum werfen. Was sind deine? Nadeln. Ja, das ist ja so leicht. Oder hatte man früher Laubbäume bei sich stehen. Oh. Aber die hatten ja keinen Laub. Die hatten ja im Winter keinen Laub. Aber damals war wiederum Weihnachten ja Ostern. Genau. März, weil die ist ja die Märzgeburtstag. Ja, ja. Nicht? So, ich möchte auf jeden Fall wissen, ab wann ziehen wir den Stecker bei dieser ganzen Ostersache, weil wir können uns ja nicht wehren. die Süßigkeitenindustrie ist uns ja voraus. Was die uns vorwirft, das schnabulieren wir, schmatzen wir, schlotzen wir einfach rein. Mein Gott, Sie haben die besten Ideen. Ja, okay, Sie haben jetzt aber auch verstanden. Sie haben jetzt aber auch verstanden. Immer die allerbesten Ideen. Ja, das haben wir jetzt auch verstanden. Ja, okay, ich sag ja nur, wenn wir langfristig, deine Aufgabe ist es primär zuzuhören, okay? Ja? Zuzuhören, mach die Augen gross und hör zu, hör mir zu.
Wenn wir nämlich die Süssigkeitenindustrie in der Tasche haben, als nächstes kommt ein Osterkalender, dann kommt der Osterkalender. Hört ihr, hört ihr, was er sagt. Mach jeden Tag ein Türchen auf, hör zuhören primär. Sie haben die besten... Zuhören primär, bitte, okay? Irgendwann verschmelzen Osterhase und Weihnachtsmann zu einer hässlichen, grässlichen Fratze. Du hast dann entweder den Ostermann oder den Weihnachtshasen. Und sobald es gruselig ist, wenn du völlig schmerzverte, täterlich, so offensichtlich gerade aus der Frankensteinmaschine entsprungen, völlig kiemen, kann überhaupt nicht atmen. Vorne Weihnachtsmann, hinten Osterhase, konnte nicht überleben. Hinten diesen grossen, sagen wir wie es ist, Hasenarsch und vorne. Der Versuch zu hoppeln, kann aber den riesigen wuchtigen Oberkörper gar nicht in die Luft stemmen. Weil er vorne diese fetten Weihnachtsmann-Schenkel hat und er ist einfach wie so ein Weihnachtsmann mit so einem riesen Ostereier, außer Hasenarsch, der so halb hoppelt, halb geht, lange Ohren hat und einen langen Bart.
Bah!
Und dann so kleine Säckchen versteckt überall.
Ja.
Der hat so ganz, der hat in seinem Sack ganz viele kleine Säckchen und versteckt überall. Und da drin ist einfach nur so Eigelb und Embryos. Einfach so ein rohes Ei eher im Sack. Oh, danke. Danke, Weihnachtshase, Ostermann. Warum hat der keinen Namen? Ostermann! Ich meine, beim Weihnachtsmann wurde ja irgendwann der Name geleakt. Santa Claus. Irgendwann hat der irgendwie mal seinen Ausweis verloren. Santa comma Claus. Ich glaube immer, dass er der Claus Santa heisst, aber er geht dran, so bayerisch dran, wie Will Florentin. Der Hund der Tupfinger, Tobias. Oh, ist der Santa Claus. Der Santa Claus. Ja, kann schon sein. Ja, er hieß Claus Santa, Santa. Aber du hast recht, es gibt keinen Namen für den Osterhasen. Melvin. Also der erste Vorschlag, den ich hätte. Mein Lord, wie wärst du mit Melvin? Melvin. Mir fällt kein Name ein. Du bist so ein verrückter Wissenschaftler, kreuzter zwei Wesen und dann fällt dir kein Name ein. Frankenstein hatte auch nie einen Namen. Das ist Frankensteins Monster. Der hatte nie einen Namen, oder was? Mit diesem Idioten-Apostroph. Das ist halt unglücklich reden raus. Denkt denen immer mit, wenn wir das sagen. Wir wissen schon, wie das heißt, aber wir sagen es trotzdem falsch. Frankensteins Monster. Ich glaube, das ist das Schwerste, dir einen Namen zu überlegen für dein schreck dein schreckliches chimären monster mir gefällt dass du weniger pedantisch wirst im alter du hast mir noch bei folge eins bis bei sich drei und korrigiert das schwierigste schwer kann man nur heben wirklich nein doch sowas doch doch das ergibt sinn das macht keinen sinn und jetzt sagst du selber einfach alles ist dir inzwischen scheißegal, Wörter, Sätze, fuck it. Boah, können wir die alten Folgen mal löschen oder so? Also können wir mal irgendwie so ein, also jetzt, ich sag, Osterfeuer oder einfach mal die den Flammen übergeben oder so? Künstliche Verknappung, künstliche Verknappung steigert ja auch unseren Wert, habe ich gelernt. Ja. Deswegen lass doch einfach weniger folgen, dann hören die ja auch mehr. Wir verdienen mehr Geld. Ja, ja. Wir machen, wir machen es ähnlich wie die faule Wolke, wir machen nur eine Folge im Jahr, die ist halt dann wirklich vier hund, vier hund, vier hund Stunden lang. Ja, vier hund, vier hund und so, sparen uns Zeit. Und dann einfach, ja, so wirklich so ein kompletter Einschlag in der, in der Podcast-Landschaft. Das wäre richtig gut. So eine riesige Folge. Mir ist es richtig schlecht durch diese Scheisse am Kopf. Kann die Kopfhaut so was annehmen? Ist dir da was ins Gesicht, also in den Mund? Meine ganzen Hände waren halt lange voll damit, das haben geklebt. Beide Hände? Ich habe so ein bisschen Angst, dass meine Kopfhaut gerade dieses Gift aufnimmt. Kann Kopfhaut ... Ich glaube, das ist so ätzend so ein bisschen. Sagt man ja immer, dass das so ein bisschen durchätzt. Sagt man ja, Vogelscheisse ätzend. Warum ist da so viel krasses Zeug drin eigentlich in Kot? Ich meine, kann man die Säure, warum produziert ein Taubenkörper Säure und haut die denn einfach raus? Ich habe immer gedacht, Natur ist super... Wholesome. Nee, effektiv. Oder effizient. Ja, okay. Deinen eigenen Feinde, die du aufgestellt hast. Okay, Florentin, du musst dein Medikament wieder nehmen. Florentin, lange sein Medikament, ich komme zum Exengestall durch. Es ist wirklich, glaube ich, sehr gut für die Welt von Pokémon, dass die Entwicklungsstufen in der Regel besser sind als die davor. Wenn ihr da draußen noch Strafzettel habt, dann sagt einfach. Weil stell dir vor, das wäre am Ende hässlicher und schwächer, wenn es sich entwickelt. Wir reden weiter darüber. Und es ist eigentlich und dann so und dann der Trainer muss, nein, hör auf dich zu entwickeln, hör auf dich zu entwickeln, weil es am Ende schwächer und schlechter ist. Ich glaube, es ist schon gut, dass es so rumgelöst wurde. In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Schickt uns eure Strafzettel unbedingt rein. Aber mit der Geschichte, nicht einfach nur schickt uns jetzt nicht einfach eure Rechnungen, eure Akten bitte, sondern wir wollen jetzt hier nicht kistenweise Akten bitte nicht mehr akten wir haben genug akten wir wissen nicht woher kommen sie sind einfach als schienweise die stehen im
ganzen keller alles voller akten um thais meide sie kümmert sich da mal darum aber der seitdem ist
weg so gott habe sie selig deswegen schickt uns bitte wirklich eine präzise und versucht jetzt
gar nichts gegen michael aber vielleicht so ein bisschen. Nee, ich will es genau so. Ich will mehr von Michael. Ich will, dass Michael mir andere Geschichten erzählt. Michael, hast du noch andere Geschichten erlebt, wo die riskant waren, wo es brenzlig war, wo es darum geht, viele Charaktere einzuführen und Örtlichkeiten und wo die sind und zueinander stehen? Es gibt ja auch so eine Behördensprache, wie wir Beamten sprechen. Und für uns ist die Behördensprache einfach die Michael-Sprache. Also falls ihr uns schreibt, dann bitte nur in Michael-Sprache, damit wir das auch wirklich gut verarbeiten können, damit wir das zu den Akten legen können, damit das wirklich einheitlich verarbeitet. Hör auf, Dinge zu den Akten zu legen. Wir haben keinen Platz mehr. Irgendwo muss es hin. Aber das Problem ist so entstanden und du hörst halt nicht auf, wenn du weiter Dinge zu den Akten legst. Ich habe viel zu viel zu den Akten.
Ich weiss.
Wir werden diese Folge jetzt auch zu den Akten legen und dann hören wir uns hoffentlich nächste Woche wieder.
Wenn alles gut geht.
Aber da muss schon viel zu sagen.
Toi, toi, toi.
Klopf auf Holz und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, sechs Mal auf Holz klopfen, so macht man das, Florentin.
Also, wir hören uns wahrscheinlich nie wieder.
Das war Stefan Tietze.
Und Florent Tambor. Bis nächste Woche, macht's gut. Das war Stefan Tietze. Und Florenton Bon.
Bis nächste Woche, macht's gut, ciao, wem ab!